can you imagine a situation where I have
to explain to my grandchildren why the
African elephant no longer exists if we
can invest our money our aid money
properly in helping people to grow their
economies sustainably then we can make
it much much more difficult for the
poachers to peddle their their business
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
LED Bibles audience the care passion is
passionately about the illegal wildlife
trade endangered species
poaching but quite often feel powerless
to enact any change what would you say -
maybe empower or encourage that Bibles
audience to become a part of tackling
well one of the reasons we're doing this
is because we know that there's
widespread public anger about the the
way in which some of our most iconic
species of suffering so for example
we're taking through legislation to ban
the sale of ivory in this country and
one of the things that's helped us
because there were some people who are
very wary about bringing forward this
law is that we had so many responses to
a public consultation so if you do make
your voice hurt whether that's signing a
petition or responding to government
consultation or backing a charity like
said SLE that does make a difference
because it always always helps if you
can point to strong passionate public
feeling on an issue I wouldn't say that
they take the natural world for granted
but we grow up whether it's in cities or
outside it with a sense that you know
that's that's part of the backdrop of
all our lives in fact one of the great
things about the extinct campaign well
is that it reinforces and this has
become widespread thanks to lad Bible
and others but the natural world is in
danger that we've we've reached a stage
where there are some species that are on
the verge of extinction unless we take
action there are a range of forces that
are converging or our generations you
know which we have a responsibility to
tackle and we know that climate change
is one and that's having an impact
actually on biodiversity but we also
know that on our watch for example the
trade in ivory is killing African
elephants at a rate that is horrendous
and unsustainable now can you imagine a
situation where I have to explain to my
grandchildren or the African elephant no
longer exists because of inaction yeah
because because we haven't done our bit
even before I was Environment Minister
the greatest number of letters and
emails that I would receive would be
about environmental and animal welfare
issues so yeah it doesn't always leave
the 10 o'clock news but it's what gets
people motivated it and it's what I hope
will will generate more action where
going to have an illegal world like
trade conference as you know just coming
up in a few weeks time and we want to
make sure that as many people as
possible feel that they can be a part of
it so it's gonna be the biggest effort
and we want to try to involve people not
just those from the countries that that
face so I know an existential threat to
some of the the species that we value
but we want to involve people in this
country as well and critically the
pressure as you know better than me from
younger people is particularly intense
and passionate and exciting as well yes
you mentioned the conference then do you
know what what's gonna be different in
two or four years time where we can go
definitively this conference changed the
way that illegal wildlife trade is being
tackled you know one thing that we can
do is we can we can spend money and we
can see how accountable we are for
supporting developing nations if we can
invest our money our aid money properly
in helping people to grow their
economies sustainably then we can make
it much much more difficult for the
poachers to peddle their their their
business charging the money that we
spend and making sure that it's spent on
bringing people out of poverty that's
one thing because ultimately this world
life is an asset to those countries as
well but there are economic pressures
that mean that it's often more difficult
for people to balance all the pressures
in developing nations but I think the
other thing that we need to do is we
need to give some thought to looking
overall at the biodiversity targets that
the UN helps steward I think
collectively you know as a world we've
got to try and put as much emphasis on
those as we have on climate change
you know the illegal wildlife trade is
worth between seven and twenty three
billion dollars a year this responsible
for twenty thousand elephants being
poached every year for the ivory once
you get governments to engage with the
serious nature of this crime then you
might see more action but how I think
you're absolutely right and and there's
a direct link between a you know the
flourishing nature of the illegal
wildlife trade the good thing is I think
that the people who are articulating
this case best are African leaders and
for that matter politicians in East Asia
as well
and I think that what we need to do is
to show that we're keeping our side of
the bog and that we're doing everything
that we can to close down the market
here and to provide support for economic
development and also give a proper
platform and that's one of the things
are calm
this is going to do to those African
leaders are showing real leadership yeah
illegal wildlife trade is part of a
wider biodiversity crisis as you
mentioned and I mean what is the UK
government doing on these other issues
that are causing this catastrophe and
biodiversity what we're doing things
both in our own country we have targets
that we're going to measure ourselves
against for restoring habitats for
making sure that world life returns to
parts of our country from which it's
been driven out but also globally we're
going to be at Cairo at the end of this
year and then Beijing next year at a
conference of parties on biodiversity
and one of the things I'm very keen on
is making sure that we have a trajectory
for improvement in this area that we all
hold ourselves to account on which is
every bit as rigorous as as what we do
in climate change so we all know that
we've got a commitment to reduce carbon
emissions what we also need to have is
international commitments across the
developing and the developed world to
reverse the destruction of nature